MESSAGE TO OTHER TRUMP ALLIES
REFUSING TO TESTIFY INCLUDING
MARK MEADOWS FRIDAY IGNORED A
SUBPOENA THIS WEEK.
JOINING US ONE OF A HANDFUL OF
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMEN WHO
SUPPORTED HOLDING STEVE BANNON
IN CRIMINAL CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS, REPUBLICAN FRED UPTON
OF MICHIGAN AND WE'LL GET TO
BANNON IN A SEC.
YOU HEARD BRYAN DEESE DEFENDING
THE WHITE HOUSE RESPONSE TO
INFLATION AND A SUCCESSFUL VOTE
ON THE BUILD BACK BETTER VOTE IN
THE HOUSE THIS WEEK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I'M NOT AT ALL
CONVINCED THAT THE BUILD BACK
BETTER PLAN IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
PASS OR EVEN BE CONSIDERED THIS
WEEK.
I DON'T THINK THE VOTES ARE
THERE YET.
A GOOD NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
DEMANDED AND ARE GOING TO
RECEIVE A CBO REPORT AS TO
WHETHER IS IT REALLY PAID FOR,
WHAT DOES IT DO WHEN YOU EXPAND
MEDICARE, WHAT DOES THAT DO TO
THE SOLVENCY.
JOE MANCHIN ASKED THE QUESTION
ABOUT INFLATION.
I CAN REMEMBER TALKING WITH
LARRY SUMMERS A FEW MONTHS AGO,
HE WAS VERY WORRIED ABOUT THE
SPENDING BY THE CONGRESS AND
WHAT IT IN FACT WAS GOING TO DO
TO INFLATION, SO SOMEHOW I DON'T
THINK WE'LL GET THESE ANSWERS TO
NECESSARILY GET THE, FOR PELOSI
TO GET THE VOTES BEFORE THE END
OF THE WEEK AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE
WIDELY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THE
SENATE ULTIMATELY MAY DO, NOT A
LOT OF DAYS IN THE LEGISLATIVE
CALENDAR YET.
WE'VE GOT THE CONTINUING
RESOLUTION WHICH WITHOUT AN
EXTENSION WOULD SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT DECEMBER 3rd, NOT TOO
FAR AWAY AND THE DEBT CEILING
EXTENSION THAT EXPIRES ON
DECEMBER 3rd AS WELL.
SO THERE ARE A LOT OF HURDLES
BEFORE THIS THING, BEFORE I'LL
SAY THIS TURKEY REALLY STARTS TO
MOVE.
>> NICE THANKSGIVING METAPHOR,
APPRECIATE IT.
ON THE BANNON INDICTMENT, OTHER
TRUMP ALLIES, FORMER CHIEF OF
STAFF MEADOWS, ARE ALSO
STONEWALLING THE COMMITTEE.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO VOTE TO
HOLD MEADOWS IN CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS?
>> WELL, WE'LL SEE WHAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE DOES.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE, THEY HAVE TO
DECIDE, THEY HAVE TO MOVE IT
FORWARD.
YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT I VOTED TO HOLD STEVE
BANNON IN CONTEMPT, HE DIDN'T
COOPERATE AT ALL.
THE ARGUMENTS WAS MARK MEADOWS
WAS HAVING HIS LAWYERS
COMMUNICATE WITH THE COMMITTEE.
SEEMED THERE WOULD BE SOME
PROGRESS THAT WAS GOING TO BE
MADE BUT YOU KNOW, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID EARLY ON HE
DID EVERYTHING TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE.
THOSE WERE HIS WORDS.
SO WE GOT TO LET THE SUN SHINE
IN, BE FULLY TRANSPARENT AND
THAT MEANS GET TO THE TRUTH,
FIND OUT EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
IF YOU STONEWALL CONGRESS, AND
I'M A FORMER COMMITTEE CHAIR, I
USE THE SUBPOENA, EVEN THE
THREAT OF SUBPOENA WAS ABLE TO
GET PEOPLE TO COME TESTIFY TO
GIVE US THE FACTS, SO WE COULD
GO AFTER FRAUD AND ABUSE, IF YOU
REFUSE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT,
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU DON'T REALLY
HAVE AN EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT TRYING TO GET TO THE
ANSWERS OF THIS.
SO FOR ME, I WANT TO SEE WHAT
THE SELECT COMMITTEE WILL DO,
SEE WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION IS
AND TAKE IT FROM THERE.
>> SO CONGRESSMAN, YOU VOTED FOR
THE BIPARTISAN $1.2 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS GOING TO SIGN
TOMORROW ALONG WITH 12 OTHER
HOUSE REPUBLICANS, 19 OTHER
SENATE REPUBLICANS.
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ON INFRASTRUCTURE
IN 2016 HE PROMISED IT WOULD BE
$VERY BIPARTISAN."
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
HE'S LEADING THE CHARGE AGAINST
REPUBLICANS LIKE YOU WHO VOTED
FOR THE BILL.
THINGS ARE SO TOXIC.
YOU'RE GETTING PHONE CALLS LIKE
THIS ONE.
>> YOU [ BLEEP ] TRAITOR PIECE
OF [ BLEEP ] PIECE OF TRASH,
HOPE YOU [ BLEEP ] DIE, HOPE
YOUR [ BLEEP ] DIES, HOPE
EVERYBODY IN YOUR [ BLEEP ]
STAFF DIES, I PIECE OF [ BLEEP ]
TRAITOR.
>> THESE ARE THREATS COMING FROM
CONSERVATIVES, REPUBLICANS,
YOU'RE GETTING THESE DEATH
THREATS BECAUSE YOU VOTED TO
FUND ROADS AND BRIDGES AND
BROADBAND.
IS IT DONALD TRUMP ATTACKING
YOU?
IS IT MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
CALLING YOU A TRAITOR AND
POSTING YOUR PHONE NUMBER?
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S A SAD DAY.
IT REALLY IS.
WE ALL KNOW WE HAVE A POLARIZED
ELECTORATE OUT THERE, DIVIDED
GOVERNMENT.
THIS BILL THAT I VOTED FOR THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS GOING TO SIGN
TOMORROW PASSED 69-30 IN THE
SENATE, WAY BACK IN AUGUST.
IT WAS A BLUEPRINT, I'M A MEMBER
OF THE PROBLEM SOLVERS CAUCUS, A
BIPARTISAN GROUP, LARRY HOGAN,
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR OF MARYLAND
HOSTED I DON'T KNOW 25, 30 OF US
BACK IN APRIL, GOVERNORS,
SENATORS, HOUSE MEMBERS, WE
DEFINED WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE WAS,
WHAT IT SHOULD BE, AND ACTUALLY
LARRY SUMMERS WAS A PARTICIPANT
AND WE ALL CONFESSED WE SHOULD
PAY FOR IT AND PAY FOR IT
WITHOUT RAISING TAXES AND THAT'S
WHAT WE DID WITH THIS BILL,
WHICH WAS WHY IT RECEIVED
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT IN THE
SENATE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM, PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S FAVORITE TOP REPUBLICAN
IN THE SENATE, SUPPORTED THIS
BILL WHEN IT PASSED 69-30.
WE NEED ROADS AND HIGHWAYS, LET
ME TELL YOU.
THIS WAS A BIPARTISAN PLAN.
IT NEEDED TO HAPPEN, AND I'M
GLAD THAT WE GOT IT PAST THE
FINISH LINE AND WE ACTUALLY TOOK
IT AWAY, REMEMBER, FOR A LITTLE
WHILE, IT SEEMED LIKE IT WAS
GOING TO BE JOINED WITH A BUILD
BACK BETTER PLAN AND WE CUT THE
CORD SO THAT IN FACT THEY WERE
SEPARATE VOTES.
>> SO THIS ALL IS HAPPENING IN
AN ERA OF MENACE AND THREATS AND
VIOLENCE.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO AN
INTERVIEW DONE WITH JONATHAN
KARL IN MARCH, HE APPEARED TO
JUSTIFY OR NOT CARE ABOUT THE
THREATS TO THE LIFE OF MIKE
PENCE ON JANUARY 6th.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> YOU HEARD THOSE CHANTS, THAT
WAS TERRIBLE.
>> HE COULD HAVE -- THE PEOPLE
WERE VERY ANGRY.
>> THEY WERE SAYING "HANG MIKE
PENCE."
>> IT'S COMMON SENSE.
IT'S COMMON SENSE THAT YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO PROTECT -- HOW CAN
YOU -- IF YOU KNOW A VOTE IS
FRAUDULENT, RIGHT, HOW CAN YOU
PASS ON A FRAUDULENT VOTE TO
CONGRESS?
>> JUST TO REMIND OUR VIEWERS,
THIS IS THE CROWD OWN THE CHANT
JOHN KARL WAS ASKING ABOUT.
[ CHANTS OF "HANG MIKE PENCE" ]
>> HOW ARERIED ARE YOU JANUARY
6th WAS NOT THE CLIMAX OR END OF
THE NEW ERA OF VIOLENCE AND
MENACE IN OUR POLITICS BUT
PERHAPS JUST THE BEGINNING?
>> WELL I TELL YOU, OBVIOUSLY I
WAS THERE ON JANUARY 6th.
I SAW THE GALLOWS THAT WERE
CONSTRUCTED ON THE EAST FRONT OF
THE CAPITOL.
I WAS NOT, THANK GOODNESS, IN
THE CHAMBER WHEN IT WAS, WHEN
THEY TRIED TO BREACH IT ON THAT
FATEFUL DAY, BUT I SAW THE
CROWD.
I SAW THE CROWD MOVE DOWN THE
MALL TOWARDS THE WHITE HOUSE TO
HEAR THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH AND
I SAW THEM COME BACK.
I TALKED TO THE SWAT TEAM
MEMBERS AFTERWARDS, PICKED UP
SOME OF THE BROKEN GLASS FROM
THE CAPITOL, OBVIOUSLY SAW THE
FOOTAGE THAT WAS THERE LIVE AS I
WAS HOLD UP IN MY OFFICE FEELING
PROTECTED, BUT IT WAS A REALLY
SCARY DAY.
THAT VIOLENCE, I MEAN, YOU LOOK
AT THE CALLS TO ALL OF US THAT
VOTED FOR THE BIPARTISAN BILL
THIS LAST WEEK, THE DEATH
THREATS THAT ARE THERE, A COUPLE
OF ARRESTS I THINK HAVE BEEN
MADE ALREADY WITH SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
WE PASSED ALONG THE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEEN SENT TO MY OFFICE
WITH PHONE CALLS AND PRESUME
WE'LL GET SOME LETTERS AND OTHER
STUFF HERE AS WELL, BUT YEAH.
IT'S A TOUGH TIME AND IT'S SO
UNSETTLING, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
NOT WHAT OUR DEMOCRACY IS ABOUT,
THESE PHYSICAL THREATS, NOT ONLY
TO OURSELVES, BUT ALSO TO OUR
FAMILY MEMBERS AS WELL AS TO OUR
STAFF.
IT IS A SAD DAY IN AMERICA, WHEN
THIS TYPE OF STUFF, I'VE GOT A
BETTER FOUR-LETTER WORD FOR IT
BUT I'LL SAVE YOU, WHEN IT
HAPPENS.
>> WE'RE NOT MANDATED BY THE
FCC, YOU CAN CURSE ON OUR AIR IF
YOU WANT BECAUSE WE'RE ON CABLE.
>> I KNOW, I WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SO I KNOW ALL ABOUT
IT.
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOU JUST HEARD
JOHN KARL ASKING DONALD TRUMP
ABOUT THE CHANTS OF "HANG MIKE
PENCE" AND DONALD TRUMP'S
RESPONSE WAS, WELL, THE PEOPLE
WERE VERY UPSET.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO DONALD
TRUMP SEEMING TO EXPLAIN AND
JUSTIFY IT ALL?
>> REMEMBER, TOO -- WELL, YOU
REMEMBER THE CALL THAT YOU ALL
REPORTED WITH KEVIN McCARTHY,
WHEN ALLEGEDLY THE PRESIDENT,
WHEN KEVIN CALLED THE PRESIDENT
TO TELL THESE FOLKS TO BACK OFF,
AND THE RESPONSE FROM MR. TRUMP
WAS, "I GUESS THEY CARE MORE
ABOUT THE ELECTION THAN YOU DO,
KEVIN," REPORTED AFTER JANUARY
OFth.
>> WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> IT'S NOT RIGHT.
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE, AND IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID IN HIS OWN WORDS, IN TERMS
OF HIS ACTIONS THAT HE TOOK THAT
DAY.
>> QUICKLY BEFORE YOU GO, SIR,
ARE YOU COMMITTED TO RUNNING FOR
ANOTHER TERM IN 2022?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT OUR DISTRICTS LOOK LIKE
YET.
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF LOOKING AT
MAPS.
MICHIGAN LOSES A SEAT, WE'LL
EVALUATE EVERYTHING PROBABLY
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR IN
TERMS OF MAKING OUR OWN